I was watching The Bert Cher podcast and
it was you guys were talking about how
much you made during your four seasons
of doing that what I'm curious about is
when you become a childhood star is
there any do they teach you about taxes
or like is there a learning curve with
like most kids when they become a
childhood star and they start making
this money like what what do you do with
all that money I don't know we're not on
there's no support group but there
should be there should be a child star
Anonymous that'd be a good show I guess
it's like Celebrity Rehab
um uh no there's no one really teaching
you and I think you just have to like
hope that you meet the right people and
hope you have like a semi trustworthy
parent which in this business is 50/50
with kid kid actors but luckily my mom
to a certain extent understood like you
you got to pay taxes yeah like let's
hold back half of every paycheck to make
sure at the end of the year we're taking
care of were you getting home schooled
or were you also going to like regular
middle school high school while filming
I went to a continuation school called
options for youth I love when people are
like where'd you go to high school I'm
like options for youth they like who is
your mascot I'm like they're like what
went wrong right um and it was great but
it was for kids who did not fit into the
standard school system so it was Teen
Moms gang members andar yeah wow wow
that's that's CRA is that a public
school yeah it is my brother wants a
continuation oh some drug
addicts where's your brother today is he
okay he's doing great yeah he's actually
got 15 years over too no way yeah is it
okay to say that yeah okay he does you
know yeah um now uh move out to
California you're in continuation school
in California yeah and
is uh the gang element the drug addict
element like introduced from school like
I'm assuming that there's like a a drug
element that it was North Hollywood
right North Hollywood it's exactly right
at the time it was a rough area I mean I
think that's the one thing that
sometimes misunderstood is like I lived
I moved from a 500 s foot apartment with
a bedroom with no windows in New York
with like a a single mom who understand
like it's just it's a [__] being a
parent regardless but doing it on your
own and and we just didn't have a lot of
money and then we moved here and we had
a little more but it wasn't crazy yeah
and uh and so we moved into a
two-bedroom apartment uh in North
Hollywood in like an elevated oak wood
and it was I mean it was 1,800 a month
and I I literally thought we were in a
palace we were like we had a pool we had
a racket ball court I'm like I didn't
know I was Elon Musk like this is
stunning and I stayed there from 14 to
29 cuz it was so I got my mom a nice
place when I was 18 but I stayed cuz I'd
never lived in a 1,000 ft apartment for
1800 bucks a month W um so yeah so
anyway that the area though it was super
transient and weird because no one lives
in these placees 16 years they live
there six months so I just remember like
drugs and all like that CD underbelly
stuff it wasn't really at school and I
wasn't exposed to it on set like the
Hollywood stuff as much it just like was
slowly around and my best friends who
weren't actors like the people I would
just hang out with after school just
it's so it's so TR that it's it's gross
cuz it's just somebody started smoking
weed and then weed was the thing and
then somebody tried something harder and
then that became the thing even though
we all told ourselves we'd only be
potheads for the rest of our lives what
was the something hard
well I mean I had friends who were you
know smoking speed in warehouses I I
didn't go that far but I mean
it's they're North Hollywood kids who
didn't you know there wasn't a lot of
foundational support there right were
you hanging out with other kids in North
like celebrities in Joseph Gordon love
it from like van I's North Hollywood
area did you guys ever link up or in
continuation were there any other
actors no no I mean I always had actor
friends I remember I started going to to
to acting class um when I was 15 thank
God cuz I had like a manager who was
like you're not good and I was like babe
I'm pretty good I'm like are you seeing
all the razzled Dazzle I'm putting on
these jokes like I have a show with my
name on it and she's like yeah but
you're not good like you're a [__]
stick machine like you're a forward
energy Dad please love me like broken
stick monster and that's not going to
work anywhere but where where you are
right now and that's proven to be
correct no um so I uh and so she's like
you got to go to acting class and so I
went and thank God I fell in love with
it cuz I'm kind of at my heart just an
acting geek anyway and in that class was
Evan Rachel Wood Dakota Fanning pen
Badgley Evan Peters like all these
killers but you know they weren't who
they are today they were just like me
like young actors who wanted to be
better and it was there where I was like
oh maybe I can do this forever cuz I I
really fell in love with it on a deeper
level then and and you were pretty pudgy
I was a heavy boy I was a thick I was a
thick boy
yes yeah what if I just denied it I was
like no I don't know what you're talking
145 on the wrestling
team um so you you fall in love with the
acting when when did you start going to
this acting class I was like 14 years
old and it became my like you know I was
choice I would I would go once a week
and then I would help like teach and by
that I mean I was I would there was a
younger kids class that they would have
the 15 16 year olds come and like assist
with the eight and nyear old kids who
were taking class and and it was just it
was my Foundation it was my my uh social
life I've told this story before so I'm
I don't think I'm speaking out of school
but I the first my first like real kiss
was during a game of spin the bottle
with Evan Rachel Wood like wow yeah and
it was ridiculous and God bless her for
for being willing to kiss a young boy
who wanted to know what that felt like
um but yeah I was 16 great shout out
Evan thank you so much I love it so were
were any man without throwing anybody
under the bus was there weed being
smoked in the acting class no those kids
were all good kids it was my it was my
street rat North Hollywood contingent it
was my still my best friend to this day
shout out Len what about Nickelodeon
were you guys like sneaking off getting
high and then going back and filming
somewhere I wasn't like in gen like I
mean like Nickelodeon kid stars of that
day like I'm sure sh lauff Amanda
bines Amanda's so great man she's just
like I she's such a great person and
then also just selfishly I think she's
literally one of the greatest performers
like I I just I want to watch her do
more stuff but she she's awesome but
yeah dude I mean there were so many I I
think I was like weirdly the exception
but because I was a a thick thick boy I
it weirdly like saved me in the ways
that I never felt even though I I had a
show with my name in it I didn't feel a
part of that crowd like that was a
different level than me like these cool
kid actors who would go to events and
clubs and look Chic and maybe were
partying like I felt comfortable amongst
my group of of buddies who were going to
Grant High School and we're just like
doing normal knucklehead [__] that kids
do not like the famous Hollywood kids
yeah there's a lot of like child stars
that have stories about being bullied
because they're stars and I can never
figure that up but was that yeah I I
went to Performing Arts High School in
New York and when I moved to LA my we
didn't know where to go my mom's like
I've heard of this place Beverly Hills I
think that's nice so we move into a uh
uh like a little apartment in Beverly
Hills for 9 months and I go to Middle
School there while I'm doing The Amanda
Show and I'm used to performing arts
high school where they're literally like
whatever you need the bigger the
opportunity the better we'll make it
easy I walk into this normal school
where they're like you're not coming for
three weeks like yeah you have algebra
and I'm like I got sng and
dance I can't make it and they were like
then you fail like we're not helping you
to skip school for months on end and
those kids sucked those kids were really
shitty and me and I was like oh this
isn't for me I'll go to school with the
Teen Moms okay my people mhm yeah my
sister was going to school with the uh
the oldest son on um Tool Time where um
Zachary Ty Bryant yeah so they're
they're we all know each other
really I remember she was going to high
school with him and it was a trip seeing
him like you know when he was in ninth
grade it's like oh dude that but like
when he goes to a party people are just
like [__] this guy not because they know
him but because they're jealous you know
it's like this guy's on TV and just
people want to hate at that age so oh
yeah I can't even imagine I mean were
you were you feeling that like when you
go to high school
parties uh yeah it was it was odd I mean
as as long ago as like in the last 10
years my wife's younger sister was going
to to uh to a college in in San Louis
abiso and they want to I was like 27 at
the time and they're they're having some
party and it's a bunch of like college
seniors and I'm there with my wife like
feeling like a chaperone and some kid
like really wanted to fight me and I was
like I I I'd want to fight me too but
why cuz I'm [__] Josh peek and what
was I
doing
sense yeah so so then you get the the
Drake and Josh show and at that point
you're like pretty into the just being
loaded no no it wasn't until the last I
was
15 great
question uh last the last season is
where sort of the wheels fell off where
I was I was I was sewing my Wild Oats as
they say but how many seasons were there
just four okay and and and and a season
per year yeah about a season per year
and it wasn't very popular um when it
was on it's only like become very
popular over the last like 10 years just
because of social media and
and it it just uh people who were you
know Young when they watched it at the
time that it was on TV they got older
and then their little sisters and
brothers watched it and then theirs did
you know what I mean so it's
weird yeah I mean there's no like
syndication like money or any of that
but I mean it's just yeah they just air
it a bunch right do you not get so you
don't get paid for syndication no
there's no residuals in kids TV are you
there no residuals and jackass I mean
not for the TV show not for the TV show
yeah I never saw a penny for for they
still play all that anybody traine
pocketing that no I mean would doubt
like I
yeah don't know I doubt it
yes wait guys is Spike Jones doing okay
I just want to make sure Spike's okay
are the producers of the show getting
I'm sure do you like shopping on Amazon
I do and and good news is sto's butt
wipes for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get sto's hot sauce for
your butthole plus sto's butthole
destroyer and steo butt wipes for your
butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right
now yeah dude